what do you make of like the anger and
the passion and all that the the firing
and the
mood swings and the madness the
um you know being emotional and all that
that's
steve and i i guess elon too so what is
that a is that a bugger feature
it's a feature so there's a graph which
is
uh y-axis productivity yeah x-axis at
zero is chaos
yeah and infinity is complete order yeah
right so as you go from the
you know the origin as you improve order
you improve productivity
yeah and at some point productivity
peaks and then it goes back down again
too much order nothing can happen yes
but the question is
is how close to the chaos is that no no
no here's the thing
is once you start moving the directional
order the force vector to drive you
towards order is unstoppable
oh every organization will
move to the place where their
productivity is stymied by order
so you need uh so the question is who's
the counter force
like because it also feels really good
as you get more organized then
productivity goes up
the organization feels it they orient it
towards it
right to hire more people they get more
guys who can run process you get bigger
right and then inevitably inevitably
the organization gets captured by the
bureaucracy that manages all the
processes right and then humans
really like that and so if you just walk
into a room and say guys
love what you're doing but i need you to
have less order
if you don't have some force behind that
nothing will happen
i i can't tell you on how many levels
that's profound so
so that's why i'd say it's a feature now
could you be nicer about it
i don't know i don't know any good
examples of being nicer about it
well the funny thing is to get stuff
done you need people who can manage
stuff and manage people because humans
are complicated they need lots of care
and feeding and you need to tell them
they look nice and they're doing good
stuff and pat them on the back
right i don't know do you tell me is
that is that needed
humans need that i had a friend he
started to manage a group and he said
i figured it out you have to praise them
before they do anything
i was waiting until they were done and
they were always mad at me
now i tell them what a great job they're
doing while they're doing it but then
you get stuck in that trap because then
when they're not doing something how do
you confront these people
i think a lot of people that had trauma
in their childhood who disagree with you
successful people
that you just first do the rough stuff
and then be nice later
i don't know okay but you know
engineering companies are full of adults
who had all kinds of range of childhoods
and
you know most people had okay childhoods
well i don't know if uh lots of people
only work for praise
which is weird you mean like everybody
i'm not that interested in this but
you